hello ladies and gentlemen my name is
ryan right today i'm going to present
the news to you that i found most
interesting in the movie industry for
the third week of august 2015 resident
evil 6 will be the supposed final
chapter in the resident evil movie
franchise fans of the movie are
disheartened by this news however fans
of the video game are jerking off to
this news scooby-doo will return to the
big screen in a new animated feature
film the new film based on the Scooby
Gang will be titled scooby-doo the
scooby gang bang get it ronda rousey
campaigns to be Captain Marvel with new
fan art using fans to try to get you a
big gig ridiculous by the way I i really
love Conan O'Brien hashtag tweet that
Conan O'Brien looks like alien 5 will be
delayed so Ridley Scott can make
prometheus 2 i'm sure prometheus 2 will
be just as loved as the first one was i
mean come on no one has any
disagreements over the first prometheus
everyone was in complete agreement
especially the ending no debates about
it everyone was on board for that stupid
[ __ ] ending looks like another reboot
of Zorro is coming this time it will be
a post-apocalyptic film
genius the graphic novel protocol
orphans is getting a television show
adaptation I'm not that familiar with
the comics other than the fact that
these characters are orphans and fight
bad guys all I know is this whoever this
lady is if she was my foster sister yeah
incest would definitely happen Christian
Bale is set to play enzo ferrari in the
michael mann's erected biopic it will
say true to the tone of ferrari
automobile owners where every character
who owns a ferrari in this film is a
rich mother [ __ ] douchebag all right
guys let's it for my movie news of the
week if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter vine and Paris Cobain and last
but not least you could catch my videos
on Latino Review com where if you are in
an illegal alien you can still view this
website